michelle barnier spoke to ambassadors
this morning i'm told he was
upbeat in that meeting that he said that
a deal was still possible but not
guaranteed he went to the european
parliament
and repeated that message before
resuming his negotiations with
lord frost uh uk's chief negotiator
there was
there perhaps still is a sort of frisson
uh of excitement in the air but let me
tell you in the past
few moments i've received some details
from a source within the uk
government about the british view of
negotiations
and it is a little more downbeat let me
tell you it is this
from a source talks remain difficult and
we have
not made significant progress in recent
days
despite efforts by the uk side to bring
energy and ideas to the process that is
of course the view from the uk
it carries on like any sovereign country
we must have the right to take our own
decisions
choose regulations that suit the uk we
cannot sign up to dynamic alignment
through the back door
it goes on the uk cannot be locked into
eu's regulatory
orbit this is clearly in relation to
negotiations around the level
playing field and that question of
whether
the uk would face some kind of
punishment as it were
if it chose to diverge from eu
regulations that is something where i
was told
a great deal of focus had been placed in
negotiations but not only that in
on fishing uh this source saying we've
always been clear the uk
will have control over access to our
waters and a better deal for uk fishing
communities
there is says this source simply no
truth to the idea
that we have backtracked that was a
suggestion that was made this morning
that the uk
had in some way gone soft uh on its
tough stance over fishing
and i think that uh rather downbeat
assessment from a uk government source
does reduce that sense of optimism
because
while the uk and the eu know each
other's positions very well
it is hard to see at this stage how you
manufacture a deal
if there is no give on fishing
now there is a great deal riding on this
d
on this set of negotiations you heard
from michelle barnier
a little earlier you've also heard today
from ursula von der line the president
of the european commission giving her
assessment
not just of the generality of brexit
talks but also
about the specifics of the level playing
field here's what she had to say
we're on the very last mile to go
but it's an essential one and we want a
level playing field
we want a level playing field not only
at the start but
also over time and this is the
architecture we are building
and we are fine about the architecture
itself
but the details in it do they really fit
and these are crucial points
because again it's a matter of fairness
it's a matter of fair competition
and we want to ensure that
we have a curious blend then at the
moment uh we have
the european commission and the
negotiators who do feel as if today they
have been
a little more upbeat uh one eu diplomat
saying
that that person could see what he
described as a narrow
path towards an agreement we now have we
know the uk striking a much more
pessimistic tone
and also the third spoke on this wheel
is the european parliament which is
beginning to flex its muscles
about its requirement to be involved in
the
the ratification process of any deal
uh it may be that a deal that is struck
at the last minute won't have time to go
through
the parliament there was and brussels is
a great city for rumors a
story that has gone around in the past
hour suggesting uh that some of the
biggest parties in the parliament
had passed a motion agreed not to do any
ratification of a brexit deal i'm told
by sources that that is
not correct but it does i think reflect
uh a complicated picture the parliament
feels it was marginalized in previous
discussions around the withdrawal
agreement
does not want to be seen as simply
rubber stamping
any future trade deal the simple fact is
that we are
rapidly running out of time i think we
are entering into completely uncharted
territory of a trade deal of this size
not having been agreed facing a very
tough deadline at the end of this year
and not for the first time i'm going to
have to sum this up as
no saying that at the moment nobody
really knows what's going to happen next